[موسيقى]
لندن تفجرها علينا فرض الاحكام العرفيه
وشن حرب مباشره ضد روسيا وكيف تطالب الغرب
بان يعتبروها حقل تجارب موسكو تلجا لخطه
تمنع هجمات الاوكران واوكرانيا تواصل
هجومها على الاراضي الروسيه وتعلن انتهاء
المرحله الاولى للهجوم المضاد فما هي
النتائج وروسيا تضع خيارين لانهاء الحرب
فهل حان وقت السلام والنيت يضم اوكرانيا
ولكن بطريقه مختلفه وهجمات سريه لقوات
بوتين تخلف مئات القتلى من جنود كييف خلال
يوم واحد المقاومه الفلسطينيه تعلن عن
مفرمه لحمه وجيش الاحتلال ينسحب بشكل عاجل
والسعوديه لايران هذه ارضنا ولن نفرط بشبر
منها واليمن يصرخ في وجه السويد واسرائيل
لندن تدخل حلبه المواجهه الغرب سيواجه
روسيا حتما هكذا تعلم الدول الغربيه ونعلم
نحن وتعلمون انتم وهذا ما تقوله موسكو على
الدوام لينقلب السحر على الساحر وتنقلب
الايه فالغرب هو من يطالب بالمواجهات هذه
المره حيث اعلن رئيس لجنه الدفاع في مجلس
العموم البريطاني قناه انه يجب على
المملكه المتحده ان تفرض حاله الاحكام
العرفيه وتشن حرب مباشره ضد روسيا ما الذي
استجد فجاه ليطلب توبيس الحرب ضد الدب
الروسي المواجهه تقترب اكثر فاكثر وهنا
كاد جندي بريطاني يدعى الكسندر جرام ان
يشعل الحرب بين روسيا وبريطانيا حين غادر
مركز خدمته يذهب للقتال في اوكرانيا عندها
قررت لندن سجنه بحسب صحيفه ذمار واما حلف
النيتو فقد اشعل التوترات مع موسكو بشكل
غير مسبوق حيث قرر الحلف انشاء مجلس
اوكرانيا الذي سيحدث اجتماعه الاول في
عاصمه ليتوانيا
[موسيقى]
في اليوم الثاني من قمه رؤساء الدول
وحكومات الحلم ومن الحرب البارده الى
المعارك الداميه على الاراضي الاوكرانيه
هنا اعلنت الدفاع الروسيه تحيد اكثر من
700 عسكري اوكراني اعلى هذه الارقام
المرعبه
ضروري نتصل بالمونتاج عشان يجيب لنا
المصدر
الو اهلا اخي عبد اللطيف لو سمحت نزلنا
المصدر حق 700 جندي اوكراني حاضر اخي
اعلنت الدفاع الروسيه احباط 17 هجوما
لقوات غياب على محاور دنيتك وجنوب دنيا
واشارت لتحديد اكثر من 700 عسكري اوكرانيا
على محاور القتال ما اعلن قائد وحده
مدفعيه في الجيش الروسي عن التصدي لهجوم
اوكراني قرب سوليدر في جمهوريه
مدرعتين والقضاء على الجزء الاكبر من قوتك
التي حاولت تنفيذ الهجوم لياتي الرد
الاوكراني فورا وذلك باعلان الجيش
الاوكراني عن تدمير تشكيل عسكري روسي في
مكيفكا التي تسيطر عليها موسكو في منطقه
دونيتسكي على خط المواجهات الامامي انزل
بالمصدر يا ابني اعلنا الجيش الاوكراني
تدميرا تشكيل عسكري روسي في ماكيفاكا التي
تسيطر عليها موسكو في منطقه دونيسكا على
خط المواجه
مسؤولون ووسائل اعلام روسيه بمقتل مدني
واصابه واحد واربعين اخرين رفق ما اعلنت
السلطات المحليه المواليه لروسيا لتوصل
قواتك على الاراضي الروسيه حيث قال حكيما
المنطقه تعرضت لنيران من اوكرانيا عبر
الحدود واعلن حاكم بالقرود وقوع هجوم على
بلده بالويكي لننتقل الى وقائع الهجوم
الاوكراني المضاف وبعد استعاده حوالي 100
كم من الاراضي التي كان يسيطر عليها الروس
يعني كل هذا الدعم وكسرت رؤوسنا بالهجوم
المضاد الهجوم المضاد الهجوم المضاد وفي
النهايه 100 كيلو صامت صامت وفطرت على
بصله لنكمل هناك تعلن عن الانتهاء من
المرحله الاولى لتبدا المرحله الثانيه من
الهجوم ليؤكد الاوكران انهم يمكن روسيا من
السيطره على البحر الاسود الاراضي التي
تتحدث عن استعاده ياه حول ضخمه اطراف
زمروجه وكما دخلت القوات الاوكرانيه الى
نار دينيفرو الذي يبلغ عرضه خمسه
كيلومترات لكن موسكو تنفي وتقول انها
افسحت المجال للاوكران في بعض المناطق كي
تستدرجهم نحو فخها ويتم محاصرتهم وابادتهم
برايكم اي الطرفين يقول الحقيقه سنترك
الاجابه لكم وسنتركها بعد ذلك للايام
والاشهر القادمه فهي كفيله باظهار الحقيقه
وهنا لجات موسكو لخطه تكتيكيه لتخفيف حده
العمليات العسكريه الاوكرانيه والهجوم
المضاد حيث قالت الاستخبارات البريطانيه
ان الجيش الروسي كثف من استخدام حقول
الالغام المضاده للدبابات اكثر مما تنص
عليه العقيده العسكريه للاتحاد الروسي
وذلك بهدف ابط هجوم الاوكراني المضاد وكان
موسكو تقول لن تحققوا شيئا من هجومكم
المضاد سوى انفجار الالغام التي زرعناها
لكن اوكرانيا لا تبالي بالخسائر وها هو
وزير الدفاع الاوكراني يقول في مقابله مع
صحيفه
تعتبر ميدان اختبار مثالي للاسلحه الغربيه
مشيرا الى انه لا يمكن تخيل ساحه اختبار
افضل من اوكرانيا لمؤسسات الصناعه
العسكريه في العالم فيا لا رحابه صدوركم
ايها الاوكران هل تقبلون بوضع انفسكم حقلا
لتجارب الغرب عن اي طلب نتحدث
واعترف بان انظمه الحرب الالكترونيه
الروسيه يمكنها احباط وقمع صواريخ
الغربيه الموجهه بنظام تحديد المواقع
العالميه اذا ثما فائده تلك الصواريخ
عندما تحييدها اصبح بالامر السهل قيمتهم
الرئيس الاوكراني فولودي مرزالينسكي روسيا
بوضع متفجرات في منشات محطه الذريه مضيفا
ان ذلك ربما لمحاكاه توجيه الضربه الى
المحطه او ربما لديهم سيناريو اخر ليرد
المتحدث باسم
في تصريحات صحفيه قائلا فان الوضع متوتر
للغايه والتهديد بشن عمليات تخريبيه من
قبل نظام تطير ومرتفع للغايه ويمكن ان
يؤدي التخريب الى عواقب كارثيه وهنا وضعت
موسكو خياراتها لانهاء الحرب حيث قال نائب
رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي بمترميدف ان انهاء
اي حرب بسرعه يكون عبر خيارين هما اتفاقيه
سلام او استخدام الاسلحه النوويه متعمدا
بذلك تذكير العالم بانهاء امريكا للحرب في
اليابان بقنبلتي هيروشيما فهل تنهي موسكو
حرب اوكرانيا بالنووي ام ستقبل بالسلام
الاحداث والتطورات
الجيش الاسرائيلي يعلن مقتل جندي خلال
تبادل اطلاق للنار اثناء انسحابه من جنين
فيما قال الناطق باسم حركه حماس حازم قاسم
نبارك لمخيم جنين ومقاومته نصره وانجازه
على الجيش الاسرائيلي ومره اخرى يهزم مخيم
جنين جيش الاحتلال نشرت وكاله رايترز
مقطعا لتجمع حشود في العاصمه اليمنيه
بحرق نسخه من المصحف الشريف على يد عراقي
في السويد كما رفع المحتجون اعلاما
فلسطينيه تمديدا بالهجوم الاسرائيلي على
مدينه جنين نقلت وكاله الانباء السعوديه
عن مصدر في وزاره الخارجيه القول ان ثروات
المنطقه المغموره المقسومه بما فيها حقل
الدره للغاز بكامله
هي ملكيه مشتركه بين المملكه ودوله الكويت
فقط اي ان ايران ليس لها اي ملكيه فيها
[موسيقى]